you want me to talk about when i come
home at night and my son's asked me what
i did today
i actually say well i had a meeting to
talk about you know what are the core
attributes of a disney princess
one of the most important things for us
is
show young women who are empowered it's
vital for us to tell stories
that better reflect the world that we're
doing business in
there's no way that you can achieve
great gains without taking great chances
i'm going to cover a number of subjects
leadership attributes how to manage
creativity
how to develop a strategy the role of
humor in the workplace is just an
extraordinary distraction and there
really is no place for humor
at the walt disney company
i'm going to tell some interesting
stories about some of the biggest
acquisitions the walt disney company has
made
there's a picture on my desk of my
shaking hands with steve jobs
that moment enabled me to say to steve i
got this crazy
idea we want to buy pixar
when you create a brand ask yourself the
question
when i put that brand name on the
product
what does it convey if i say to you
disney
you know exactly what it is there's a
feeling inside you you immediately have
a visceral feeling about it
my greatest hope for the next generation
of business leaders
is that they bring to the job great
integrity
and they achieve things that ultimately
create a better world
and a future that looks brighter than
the present
i'm bob iger and this is my master class
you